already today's talk is about building a
knapsack program with zero budget I love
it and going beyond you know I washed
top ten Chris Romeo is the CEO and
co-founder of security Johnny and they
have a lot of educational materials on
their website he specializes in online
application security training organized
as a security belt program he is he will
love you to connect with him on LinkedIn
and follow him and you know be involved
in the podcast and stuff and without
father I do Chris so yeah just a couple
other things here about me I do I'm the
co-host of the application security
podcast I've been hanging out in the
members lounge yesterday interviewing
lots of interesting people so if you
want to kind of hear about some of the
people that were at the conference maybe
you didn't get to hear their sessions
I'm also part of the OWASP triangle
chapter that's back in Raleigh North
Carolina which is my home and I'm
definitely glad to be here today even
though I'm far from home glad to always
be in a no ospa vent always guaranteed
to be a rule an unruly crowd or you know
lots of lots of fun along the way so
here's what I want to talk about with
you today from this idea of building an
application security program so very
quickly I'm going to talk about the
traditional app sect programs and
security community and then I'll get
into my thoughts and ideas about how you
can actually build an app sect program
using just the things that you have in
the OWASP universe so when I say Oh wasp
universe that just means everything you
can find on the OWASP webpage and so
we'll talk about some of the different
categories there so if we think about
traditional app sect programs we're
gonna have to we have to just quickly
discuss what that means to you
understand how we're gonna fit the
various ojas pieces into the this kind
of a mold and so if you think about kind
of traditional definitions people
process tools on the people side you've
got everybody that you're trying to get
in your organization that's gonna be
doing things for security you've got
your developers your testers your
program managers your product managers
people managers executives on the
process side you may or may not have a
secure development lifecycle that's at
the core
drives your program you may have product
security incident response bug bounty
all of these are processed related
pieces that we need to have then on the
tools side we've got SAS desk
I asked rasp all of these different
types of tools and technologies
vulnerability scanning we've got
dependency checking so all of these are
the traditional pieces if you go into
any big organization and and you take a
look at their applications security
program these are the pieces that you're
gonna find for those that have a lot of
money to spend and so I think it just
helps to set that framework before we
talk about what we can do on kind of
from the OWASP universe and so
regardless of how much money you have to
spend I think you have a common set of
goals for an application security
program I think at first it starts with
just limiting vulnerabilities and
deployed code that's really what we all
want to do regardless of how much money
we had to spend in the process we want
to be able to build secure software and
teach developers how to code securely
that's always going to be a goal of ours
we want the processes we want maturity
but it really comes down to how do we
limit those vulnerabilities in in the
code that's being created and so I can't
I created this this talk and this idea
after I thought this question must have
been answered before I thought somebody
must have answered how can you take all
the pieces from the world of OWASP and
put them together into a program I
looked and I looked and it wasn't there
and so I said you know what I'm gonna
take that as a challenge and I'm gonna
try to to look and everything in the
OWASP universe and figure out how I can
filter it and put it in the different
sections to actually make something that
could become a program and so and just
remember I mean everybody in this room
you're here you love OAuth already so
you know just because it's free doesn't
mean it doesn't have a lot of value so
just because we're talking about
something that might be free Oh wasp
stuff is still gonna be some of the best
stuff better than some of the things
that you can actually spend money on and
so I'm also a realist and I know that
not everybody's gonna be coming at this
problem with a budget of exactly zero I
know some people are gonna have large
budgets some people are gonna have small
budgets the the advantage of approaching
this through the kind of lens of the
world of a wasp is even if you have
budget there's still a lot of cool
things in OWASP it's you can use to
make your program better maybe save a
little bit of money but it doesn't
necessarily mean this is only for those
with with no money but if you have a
small budget you can really plug in some
things into your program that'll make it
make it a lot better and so I got a I
just got to mention security champions
because security champions is this idea
of gathering people who are passionate
about security getting them engaged
getting them to to to be your eyes and
ears on the ground so say you have five
so you have two applications security
programs it's two people in your program
and you have a thousand developers
security champions is how you magnify
your voice and magnify what you can
actually do by engaging other people and
so I mentioned this up front because all
the other sections I'm gonna talk about
are gonna be dependent on security
champions to be successful you have to
have this boots on the ground type of
group who can help you in all the
different areas that we're gonna talk
about here
so I came to this in in the way I
approach this is I started with the
OWASP project inventory and so if you
know in the os project inventory they
they tag projects as various different
classifications whether its flagship lab
projects or incubators based on how
mature an individual project is and so I
kind of started at the top with the
flagship projects and then I made my way
down through until I got to incubator
and as you know and if you have a
project in an incubator or you've used
any of them they are not necessarily
production ready there sometimes
alpha-beta maybe something that
somewhere in between but that's okay I
still gave them my consideration when I
was trying to figure out what we could
use so then I also built this what I'll
call my scale of project risk here if
we're gonna take if we're gonna use open
source projects and things and embed
them into a program we at least have to
be thinking about what is the risk or
potential for this project to just go
away because if we're gonna if we're
gonna bet our whole program on a two or
three projects we at least have to be
thinking about is this something that's
so new that it may not haven't ever have
another release or it may this may this
may be something that you know I've got
a lot of risk from so I rated these from
zero to ten zero being you know
this project is not going anywhere if it
goes away a wasp is gonna be gone and
then none of this other stuff will
matter and then all the way through you
know stable to newer projects to older
projects that haven't been updated in a
long time to ten which if I added one of
those then you should wonder why I even
added that to the project so just
remember that there is no guarantee that
you're any project that you use here is
gonna exist it's just that's just the
OWASP way I mean we can feel pretty good
about some of the projects that have
been around for ten years and stuff but
it's just it's no guarantee so I broke
these projects into three primary
categories here so if we're gonna build
a program we're gonna have to start
thinking about some smaller pieces for
how we how we chunk these things
together and so the categories
themselves are awareness and knowledge
and then processing measurement and then
tools so the first one is awareness what
I'll call awareness knowledge and
education okay there's with this
particular grouping there's probably not
a lot of surprises here if you've been
around the OWASP universe but what I
found when I started doing this research
and looking at all these different
projects is there's so much stuff out
there and OWASP that I was finding
things I had never heard of I had never
heard of the automated threat handbook
before I started digging into this I
just I guess I never had a need for it I
never started I never looked for it but
when I was going through the list
looking I was like wow this is really
cool this is a very mature document and
so you will find things along the way so
let's let's look at each of these real
quick and kind of break down what I see
is the risk so you know the OWASP top 10
it's everybody knows this well I'm not
gonna spend much time on it I mean I
think it's got a risk of 0 because this
is the flagship product of the entire
the entire a wasp world it's it's I
think of this as an awareness document
though I think so many people and I know
it's probably not the people in this
room but a lot of people who are looking
at making requirements for when they buy
things say they use the OWASP top 10 as
a requirements document and a
requirements beckon and for me it's an
awareness document I want my developers
to to understand each and every one of
these things and to know what each of
those attacks actually means and how
they work but it's not a set of
requirements but very very low risk from
my perspective of including OWASA top 10
as you
imagine okay proactive controls how many
people were aware of proactive controls
raising hand real quick okay all right
so about half the room I was the same
way
I didn't I didn't know about this until
I'm actually got it I got invited and
had a chance to contribute on the 3.0
the latest version of this that came out
and that's when I really dug into it
this is this is a set of controls for
developers that is designed to be kind
of an inverse to the OWASP top 10 this
is what you want developers to do to
prevent the the OWASP top 10 from ever
occurring in your web applications I
mean look you got secure database access
that is your sequel injection counter
you've got encoding an escaping data
that should cross-site scripting
balance thing that balances cross-site
scripting out and so proactive controls
it's it's once again an awareness
document I gave it a risk of - that's
pretty low on the scale I think this is
gonna exist for a long time as well
automated threat handbook with this with
this document I don't really want
developers to memorize this like I want
developers to be able to recite this
that these ten things from the proactive
controls in their sleep that's how much
I want them to know this something like
the threat handbook this is more of I
just want them to know it exists I don't
need them to be able to explain to me
what is a credential stuffing attack
well I mean it would be nice if they
could but I don't need everybody to be
able to do that if I can just get them
to know there is this document called
automated threat handbook and it's a
reference so if they're thinking of if
they encounter something that they think
is an automated threat they can go to
this document look it up and read the
descriptions that are in there I'll
consider that a win I gave that a three
just because that's a little bit of a
newer project than some of the other
ones okay oh wasps cheap cheat sheets
this is the short and sweet version that
developers love on how to do almost
anything you can think of in the world
of application security so I mean take a
look at some of the things you see on
this list access control logging
password storage sequel injection
prevention transport layer protection
the beautiful thing about the cheat
sheets is they are short and sweet and
they're to the point so that developers
when they go to read them there's not a
lot of fluff because a lot of people in
this room are developers I know you
don't want to go read five pages before
you get to the good stuff that actually
tells you how to
answer the question that you had you
want the short and sweet version the
team that works on the cheat sheets has
done a great job there's been well you
know I don't know hundreds of authors
that have contributed these cheat sheets
some companies that have thrown their
stuff in so once again a very good
reference type of resource I want to I
want in our program I want our
developers to know that this exists
again and know that have an index to
what's available here so they can go
search it out see security knowledge
framework okay this is a a wasp project
that it uses the ASVs the Apple Utley
application security verification
standard the requirements it uses that
and then it also provides code samples
for how to meet the security
requirements of ASVs in each of these
languages correctly so this is a this is
a tool that I want developers to just
have the ability to reference
I want this running as part of our
program so that the developers can go to
this they can say okay I'm dealing with
a particular type of issue and then they
can say I want to use Java or whatever
and then they can look at a particular
piece of code like cross-site scripting
filtering there's a Java specific
example for that so I want them to be
able to look at those those pieces of
code and kind of see where we're at
hands-on training so wasp has a lot of
great stuff in the hands-on training
perspective what I mean by this is these
are vulnerable web applications that
developers can go and they can actually
try to break stuff this is a great way
for developers to learn about the OWASP
top ten and even the proactive controls
is to go through and break stuff along
the way and so there's three things I'm
highlighting that I recommend for from a
programmatic perspective on the hands-on
training perspective webgoat has been
around almost as long as Olas maybe
longer I can't remember but it's a it's
an OAuth top ten vulnerable application
written in Java and it's it's quite good
dev slop is a relatively new project
where the team is putting together micro
services in a DevOps environment that
are vulnerable so trying to help people
expose some of the other security issues
that can exist in the micro services
world
and then juice shop out of these three
juice shop has the most it's the most
setup for like a capture-the-flag type
of an environment and it has the most
types of different types of attacks and
things that you can find there so part
of this is from this awareness
perspective is let's get our developers
to actually put their hands on keyboards
and start doing some stuff here risks of
these I say is three so it's everything
you've seen so far has been relatively
low risk to include into a program from
my perspective so as I was doing this
analysis I thought okay what's missing
from these what are the pieces that
you're gonna have to figure out on your
own that I can't give you an OS piece to
actually do and so the missing pieces in
this section are how are you gonna
deliver that you got to figure out how
to deliver the proactive controls the
top ten the automated threat framework
the the hands-on tools how you gonna
deliver those back to your user base
that's something you'll have to figure
out how you gonna administer you know
the juice shop platforms somebody's
gonna have to be assigned to kind of do
that so here's where I think you here's
what I think the impact is and
ultimately for each of these sections
I'll give you what I think the headcount
requirement is to really do this
correctly because even though we have a
budget of zero we're still gonna need
some people to help bring this together
because you don't have a couple of
people driving this then good luck with
with trying to get any type of really
impact so I think on the on the
awareness side with the top ten the
proactive controls it's really just
about let's get some foundational
understanding of these concepts to every
developer in the organization on the
knowledge side we got those secure
coding examples which are huge and then
with the hands-on training I mean I can
tell you it's just there's something
about when you take developers who have
not done a lot with security and you put
them in front of the keyboard and let
them actually try different types of
attacks and things it just it changes
the way they view their own applications
in the future and so there's a huge
impact to be found there okay
how can you what what are what are some
real quick ways you can start with these
so on the awareness side you can just
you lunch and learns are a great way to
approach this do a lunch and learn for
the OWASP top 10 do it for the OWASP top
1 focus on injection as one
one particular lunch-and-learn on the
knowledge side it's more about like I
said it's more about awareness of the
cheat sheets having the cheat sheets
available maybe internally doing a
training session on one of the cheat
sheets just to show developers how to
actually use them on the hands-on
training side you're gonna have to build
out some of these and like juice shop
makes it very easy you can actually they
have a deploy to Heroku button so you
can actually with one button click you
can deploy your own juice shop instance
and then you can point your developers
to that in the cloud if you really want
to be able to get something like juice
shop going quickly and that hackathons
are a great way to approach using juice
shop I did that with our wasps chapter
in Raleigh North Carolina we set up a
number of juice shop instances in the
cloud had a had a bunch of developers so
we did it over lunch so it wasn't like
the traditional evening meetup had a
bunch of developers and that had never
done anything with app sect before
invited him into the room had about five
or six security people and maybe twenty
or thirty developers with no security
background and it's fun to watch
developers start tearing in the juice
shop when you got people that really
know how to code and they start trying
to break something like there they were
they just really got into it so that's
that's a great way to approach that one
so that's that's kind of the awareness
and training side let's talk about
process and measurements so some of the
process pieces that we can bring in here
so first we have in the OWASP universe
you have Sam the software assurance
maturity model what Sam does is it gives
you a catalog and a way to measure where
your program is right now and so the
importance of Sam when you're trying to
build this program for $0 or with it
without any type of cost is Sam really
gives you a couple things and gives you
a way to to measure where are we today
with our overall approach to the program
it also gives you a whole bunch of
things to look forward to in the future
you can you can reverse engineer Sam to
say where can we go with our program
because Sam has different levels for
each of these things like let's say
threat assessment they have different
levels of maturity and so if you measure
yourself a threat assessment we as your
your program with a level one you can
look at level two and say okay what
should I be aiming for what should I be
so this can actually help you to guide
your program
and build a strategy for how you how you
move things in the future Sam has been
around forever so there's almost no risk
to that ASVs
is the set of requirements that was--
the document that Olaf puts out with
requirements they're broken into each of
these categories focused on web apps
specifically across all these different
different types of categories ASVs is
broken down also into individual levels
as far as how the requirements are
tiered based on how but how you know
what is the what is the the kind of
threat landscape look like for your
individual application you can tier ASVs
to meet that the point with this is a
lot of organizations try to build their
own set of requirements and they take
inputs from other places but if you
don't have an existing set of
requirements now ASVs gives you a nice
place to start with that requirement
base okay so threat modeling on the
process side I'm a huge proponent of
threat modeling of teaching developers
how to analyze the security of the
features that they're working on and and
just discover any of the types of
problems they can find before things get
too far down the work down the line and
so there's a project OS project
application threat modeling I put the
risk you'll notice pretty high on this
one there's there's a lot of change
that's happening with this project right
now there's some a lot of new people
that are bringing different ideas and
they're trying to organize their
messaging and everything along the way
so so still very worthy but just there's
there's some kind of changes and things
going on there okay if we're gonna do
process we're gonna we're gonna have to
talk about code review we need to be
able to give our developers a standard
to help them follow through in the code
review process and that's what this
oh-ah stock youment does it provides the
process for you and then it gives your
developers all the different types of
things that they need to be looking at
as they're going through and looking at
their own code it's even got you know
review checklists and and just a lot of
really great stuff there about how to do
the code review along the way and then
you've got the OWASP testing guide the
of all the documents i've seen in the
OWASP universe the testing guide really
does a great
of explaining concepts and how to do
things like if you go look at the
cross-site scripting
section of the OWASP testing guide they
spend like three pages on how to test
for various cross site scripting
scenarios and they really given a very
detailed description with screenshots
and things and so this document becomes
your your process and your knowledge
base for how do you want people to test
in this new program so what are we
missing here in the process side so
we're missing that overall end-to-end
secure development lifecycle or secure
STL c30 at this stage for some reason
and I don't know why there is no Oh wasp
secure development lifecycle project
nobody has actually said okay let's try
and build an open version of the process
for agile for DevOps is how you build
security in and how do you how you shift
things left so you're not gonna be able
to pull that from the from the from an
OS project but you can put together a
number of the things I'm talking about
here into an SD L if you're starting
from scratch one of the other things
that's missing here is the program
metrics so you're gonna have to design
your own way to determine how well
you're doing in this process whether
that's measuring time to fix bugs that
about to identify two security bugs over
time that's a great metric to use to do
that but there's really not a metrics
project that helps us along that way and
then deployment advice so so here is so
here's the impact from both the process
of measurement and and I really envision
you're gonna need one and a half people
to be focused to do this well when I say
one-and-a-half people for like process
and measurement I'm thinking about you
know a decent-sized organization with a
thousand developer so if you scale
yourself down and say you're a hundred
developers you know you can scale this
this isn't going to be as big of a kind
of commitment from head count as far as
what you need to be successful so on the
process side I mean ASVs is all about
the requirements that's your
requirements base if you don't have
anything moving forward the app threat
modeling is you
the process there they've got some good
examples on that wiki page and so that's
that's a good one to work from the code
review the testing guide these are your
process for how you do those things
these are your instructions to teach
people how to do it as well and then on
the measurement side you know we really
need that roadmap we need we need that
Sam roadmap for where we are today and
where we want to get to in the future
and that's what the Sam project does for
us so how do we get started with these
two how do we be successful so on the
process side you kick I don't I don't
really don't think you can do all of
these things at the same time I don't
think you can implement code review
testing requirements threat modeling you
try to do all even two out of those four
at the same time and it's gonna be very
very difficult so my recommendation is
when you're trying to get started in
doing this
pick one thing out of that list and
focus on that in your first six months
or one year I like to go to threat
modeling because I think that has the
highest rate of return for the amount of
effort that you put in to actually
embedding it into your program and into
your organization but don't try to boil
the ocean don't try to do everything at
the same time break it down and do one
thing at a time on the measurement side
I mentioned doing that early assessment
creating the future plan sharing share
these assessments with anybody that'll
listen your champions group they should
be aware of where we are where we want
to go executives have you got executives
that'll listen please tell them all
about this stuff
and ask them to kind of help you along
the way but one of the things executives
are gonna want to see here and what Sam
does for you is they're gonna want to
see where are we today
if if we move forward with your plan
where do you think we can get to and the
nice thing about that is Sam gives you
those pieces it'll help you in framing
that strategy so you don't have to
create it from scratch and just try to
try to create something you can use the
pieces of Sam to make that argument for
you okay last category here that I have
is the tools section so a couple of
different tools that and and this I
would say is the most disjointed
category that I have because these
things as you're looking at this list
they kind of all fit into different
places in the in the development
lifecycle
Oh wasps threat dragons so I put this
one in here and this is a relatively new
project at OWASP and it is the crickets
it's a web app that allows you to do
threat modeling right in the browser and
store your store your threat models and
github this one is I put this as a risk
of five this is still an alpha status
right now but I'm such a proponent I
love threat modeling so much I really
want to see this be successful as a
project because I think it has a lot of
value in that it helps you to capture
the process so you can just point a
developer to this and say okay draw a
picture of the feature that you're
working from and then the tool will help
you to make your way through at least
the initial threats and so I think that
this tool is a great learning thing for
developers because I think of threat
modeling really is more of something
that I want developers to know and to
just understand over time and so we have
threat dragon that's a good way to kind
of start help them get there we can't
have an occasion security program
without CRS the core rule set with mod
security boiled into it it's just such a
mature project here and what this allows
you to do is this becomes your Web
Application Firewall sitting in front of
your applications like I said this is
this is a category where there's a lot
of things kind of thrown in together but
you know court the Court Rule set on
with mod Security's going to help you to
block the OWASP top ten style attacks
that are coming inbound into your
applications this is more of an
infrastructure play than any type of
thing that that's going to directly
influence your developers I mean you're
gonna have this is gonna get built into
your infrastructure and then it's gonna
be a part of that into the future
okay then we've got dependency check I'm
who uses dependency check right now okay
awesome I'd love to see that's more than
half ok dependency check very simple
souls a very simple problem but this is
a very mature product that solves that
problem what it does is it allows it
checks to see do you have any known
vulnerabilities in the third-party
software that you are using in your in
your applications commercial versions of
solving this problem cost
if not hundreds of thousands of dollars
and this is a Noah's project that it's
pretty close to feature they're pretty
close in their feature parity with what
you can spend a lot of money on here and
so I love this project because and also
because it's so easy to put in you can
install you can add dependency check to
your build pipeline in about 30 seconds
to a minute it's it's very simple to add
in now I mean it might brace it now if
it breaks a bunch of stuff if you got a
bunch of old software that's on you okay
but the 30 seconds part is just to add
the tool in to the process okay it'll
tell you if you've got those problems
it'll kick it out to report it look it
uses lots of different languages it's
got plugins for all your different build
pipeline type of stuff you're doing
great project they just added a new
piece to this I don't even have on here
it's called dependency tracker which
gives you more of the enterprise
management side to it so that makes it
even more awesome yes sir
national vulnerability database so this
is the US government's standard source
for CD ease to get recorded and so
dependency check ingest those
automatically for you so you don't even
have to update it as far you can you
don't have to tell it about
vulnerabilities it gets it all from
there the feed there so okay then we've
got zapped everybody knows zap if you've
been in the OWASP world for more than
five minutes you've heard somebody tell
you about zap you've been to a meet-up
to talk about it zap is your proxy based
testing tool some would say it is
similar to a dynamic application
security testing tool some would say
it's not some would argue with me to the
death about that but but yeah it's a
great tool it's very mature it's been
around for a long time it allows it in
conjunction with the OWASP testing guide
this is a it's a tool your testers are
gonna need in your program to be
successful as they make their way
through with the testing guide ok so
what's missing here in the tools
perspective in the OWASP universe so
first of all you'll notice I and maybe
somebody knows about something I don't
but I don't see any up any real Olas
pieces for static application security
testing or you know static analysis now
I know there are a few different open
source tools that people that I've heard
about that people use for Python and
and some of the other languages Java
fine I think fine bugs or something so
you may be able to plug something else
in here my point was there really isn't
anything from the OWASP world that that
I can slot in here and then so the other
thing that I think we're missing is
there's really no dashboard and and I
may after I learned about something
called defect dojo yesterday
is anybody anybody from no diffuse
defect dojo okay so I think and this
just tells you how big the OWASP
universe is I thought I looked at
everything to do this and I think DFAC
dojo slipped past me and I think defect
dojo would actually do this piece that I
say is missing so I got out a slide here
I'll do it later though so yeah so I
think that'll give you that dashboard so
I actually don't think that's missing I
think defect dojo solves that problem
for us so so your impact so on the
design side threat dragon just helps you
to make the process a reality on the
infrastructure side CRS gives you that
laugh dependency checks looking at your
third-party stuff zaps gonna do
something similar to your desk and
plugins plugins to various other things
so how do you use this how do you get
started with it so I think taking threat
dragon and including that making in
pointing your development teams to it at
least in a pilot mode is a way to get
that get them start thinking about
threat modeling the challenge here is it
is still alpha right now so it's a
little bit it's it's it's not getting us
it's a little bit it's not feature
complete anywhere near but it does
actually work and it can actually be
used on the infrastructure side I mean
add dependency check to your build
pipeline tomorrow I mean that's that's
how serious I think and how easy I think
it is to get the value that comes out of
that get zap to the testers you know get
mod security with CRS into the
infrastructure that you have I think
those are all those are all doable
pieces that you know shouldn't be
shouldn't be huge so if we total up kind
of all the headcount summary that I
think we need to be successful here I
mean you're at basically four and a half
people to really do all of these things
at the same time and really roll it out
fast now that doesn't necessarily mean
that's the best way to even approach
this problem though I would say you can
you can work with whatever the head
now whatever you have as far as
resources that can be dedicated to doing
this you can focus them you're just not
gonna be able do everything at the same
time you're gonna have to say okay let's
start with something on the awareness
side let's just get a Austin out there
proactive controls pick something we can
do it hands-on training we can introduce
some of the knowledge tools some of the
process stuff with the ASVs and the
requirements side so pick a small piece
don't necessarily try to do all this
stuff at the same time so here's the
here's all of everything I've talked
about today in one slide I probably
should have started here I could have
started with this slide talk for five
minutes and then dismiss the class maybe
but just so you can see when it all
comes together and you notice I've got
security champions and security
community here riding on this side
because that is such an important piece
of kind of what we're doing here is the
security community side of it all of
these different pieces they all fit
together there's probably even more
stuff that I could put into this but and
when we get to Q&A you can tell me what
I missed because I had that I actually
got the security knowledge framework I
didn't have this originally and I did
this talk for our local OWASA chapter as
a warm-up and and somebody raises their
hand and said what about security
knowledge framework and I said what's
that and then he explained it to me like
oh I gotta put that in if you think
about this from the SDL perspective I'm
a big security velum a life cycle person
so if you think about it so I thought I
would just give you the same information
from the previous slide if you want to
think about this from the SDL
perspective so same these are all the
same tools I talked about already I just
put them into the nice categories of a
high level Microsoft like SDL is this a
DevOps SDL no this is this is higher
little higher level if we want to talk
about how that fits in DevOps world we
got to go a little bit deeper so here's
my final thoughts and then we'll do some
questions and answers so I mean open Sam
I can't say it enough and that that's
the tool that allows you to really plan
where you are and where you're going
I've already said a number of times
there's no security element lifecycle
here you know wasp but all as you saw
the component pieces are
all here it's just we don't have it in a
document where it all fits together
nicely we want to start small pick one
of those things start with the top 10
start with proactive controls you know
start with one of those pieces and use
that as the way to launch the security
community and champions you can't do
this without somebody helping you if
you're gonna do it with a very small
budget you're gonna have to have some
group of people and just to you know
kind of hit on that one more time you'll
find that there are developers in your
organization now that are passionate
about security and if you don't know who
they are you just got to find him okay I
promise you doesn't matter how big I'm
not telling you're gonna find a hundred
people if you only have 150 developers
you might get lucky but there's at least
a few and they're willing to help you do
all of these things you just have to tap
into them you just have to you have to
engage them you know figure out where
you want to go from a one to two year
plan if you don't have all the resources
upfront and just remember you know while
a wasp is free all the components all
the projects and things are free there
is still some amount of headcount
required to bring all these things
together and build out this program so
with that I left us 9 minutes I think 2
for questions and answers and also share
with me the things I've missed in this
I'd love to add more stuff to this yes
sir we'll start here yeah he's gonna
yeah he'll bring in a microphone to ask
your question this is super i opening
thank you i've never actually even
viewed Oh awesome this way and in my
mind I'm starting to think of some of
the gaps and I think they're operational
gaps I don't know if identifies that way
but what I see missing is like bug
bounty ingestion Incident Response
support like how to how to keep records
and coordinate incidents and the other
one would be like ingestion of
vulnerability information just like from
customer reports of vulnerabilities yeah
yeah no and I think I think you got a
couple of good things you're mentioning
there so I haven't seen yet anything I
really haven't seen bug bounty come up
in the OWASP universe yet
and if somebody please correct me if I'm
wrong because as you saw there's a
million parts here and it was very good
to be very easy for me to have missed it
but I haven't seen bug bounty really and
the P search side so I think there's
there's definitely to fill this out this
plan that I have I think there are some
pieces that could be added to it and
those are those are two great examples
yeah hopefully this is a call to action
start new projects I think what I think
one of the things I'm gonna do is I
think I'm gonna take this and put it
into a project I thought you know what
I've gone through and done all the work
already I might as well create a project
and just dump all this into it and then
maybe update it in a year or two but
that way at least it would it could
perhaps take on a life of its own and
other people might be able to add to it
as we go as well so that's my plan
coming out of this all right any more
questions yeah yeah I like oh no we're
dot yeah that's true yeah no I'm I'm
gonna keep it simple person to so keep
it simple alright that was the this
somebody's got to have a hard question
because I'm an expert at deflecting hard
questions back to someone else in the
audience it's a gift I have just give it
back like what do you think about that
yet there thank you so it like the guy
said at the front it was really great to
see all of those things in in that
format because actually go into the
OWASP website is a complete nightmare
trying to find stuff so taking that are
there any plans do you know or is
someone gonna be working on the website
to make it easier to find this stuff to
identify it even if you're struggling to
find the the dojo application what what
hope for us yeah I think I've heard
various efforts are underway to revamp
the wiki and
get better and make it harder to find I
think it's just a heart is a hard
problem to solve when you think about
the number of resources that Olas has on
the employee side as far as what they're
doing so I'm not I'm not aware of any
specific things but yeah I agree with
you after you know I mean I I went to
the the project inventory and I started
at the top and I went through and
clicked on everything and read and some
projects I could tell we're dead and I
just let them you know I ignored him
because I could tell they were dead but
yeah there's this is a hard problem in
that we have so many projects out there
in this and we got to find a better way
to index them but hopefully we'll get
something in the next year or two
based on what I've heard from different
forums and stuff so
you said you would start processes with
threat modeling so I wonder how would
you scale that how much would you let
the developers and architects do
themselves or where would you include
security experts yes so the that's a
that is a great question about scaling
threat modeling so if you're able to get
some security community folks and some
champions I think that's always the best
way to go if you're in an environment
where you just don't have those people
yet they're just not there
what I've done in the past is I just
started I just started going and meeting
with various developers and threat
modeling with them the thing about
threat modeling is I can sit up here and
give a four hour lecture on it and after
about five ten minutes
you've already checked out of that with
threat modeling we got to jump in and go
we just got to start doing it and that's
really the key so if you're starting
small and you don't have a big group I
would say if you understand threat
modeling you just go meet with a couple
developers a couple architects go to the
whiteboard start drawing teach them and
then hopefully they will begin to teach
other people as you go I think that's
the model when you don't have a lot of
money to to be able to roll out of a
formal kind of a threat modeling
approach thank you all right last call
anyone else any other questions
yes you identified a gap for the for an
OS offering for secure software
development lifecycle yeah yesterday
morning we had a nice talk from a
gentleman who has held a presentation on
that and I don't know if he was ready to
like make that an official or wast
project but he's apparently working on a
on a more on a book or a paper about
that and maybe it would be interesting
to see if he could contribute in that
yeah definitely I'll try and track it
down I'll look and see I look at the
things I can find of me I think that'd
be great I'd love to see a secure
development lifecycle high-level kind of
an agile spin a DevOps bin exactly he
touched upon exactly all those different
mythologies yeah but we won't create a
waterfall one oh no oh no no we don't
want anybody to think that's okay to
continue in that direction so yeah
there's one more question over here and
then I'm gonna say then I'm gonna go
it's a bit more to the back from its
right modeling when you say you sit with
the developers is it also something you
would do with customers directly I've
never done I've never done threat
modeling with customers directly that
would probably be a pretty interesting
if you had customers who were willing to
sit there and actually go through and
consider it that being interesting I
would if somebody would do it it'd be an
interesting conversation so thanks
everybody for your time I'll be around
for the next couple hours out here so
thank you
[Applause]